i wish i could say the last night that i
ever touched heroin
was the night of my overdose but it
wasn't demi lovato reveals she relapsed
on heroin
after the 2018 overdose that nearly took
her life
i thought how did i pick up the same
drugs that
put me in the hospital
i was like mortified at my decisions
she was even surprised at just how much
she ended up wanting to share
um which is all about the safe space
and the ability you know to ultimately
get our story out there
episode three of the i love me singers
four-part docu-series dancing with the
devil
dropped tuesday on youtube and the 28
year old entertainer
opens up about using drugs again after
her 2018 overdose
i had just done
a week-long intensive trauma retreat
the night that i came back from that
retreat i
called him i wanted to rewrite
his choice of
violating me i wanted it now to be my
choice
and he also had something that i wanted
which were drugs and
yeah i ended up getting high the him
demi is referring to
is her drug dealer who in an earlier
episode
demi alleged sexually assaulted her the
night of her overdose
when they found me i was naked i was
blue i was literally left for dead
after he took advantage of me and demi
says she called him in an attempt to try
to rewrite history
i called him back and i said
no i'm gonna [ __ ] you and
it didn't fix anything it didn't take
anything away it just made me feel worse
but that for some reason was my way of
taking the power back
all it did was bring me back to my knees
of
begging to god for help demi's case
manager
charles cook says she called him for
help
how do we help you create a life where
to have a sense of
autonomy does not mean putting yourself
in these harmful situations that being
able to you know
abuse your abuser is not where the
healing is going to come from
when eti caught up with the
documentary's director michael d
ratner he said that while he has worried
about demi
he also knows she is doing the work to
heal
so growing close with her spending all
this time and
seeing how much she was still on a
journey while you were filming
did you worry about her yes you know i
mean
you're when you're when you're when
you're learning and
understanding if you're really going to
pay attention and listen
when entering a world filled with trauma
and addiction and a storied history
you'd be foolish not to worry in some
capacity
i also need to be respectful of
boundaries and know
that you know i'm there to document the
story i've been
producing directing tons of different
work sometimes it's
lighter and a comedy and i can go eat
dinner that night and i go to set the
next day and i'm ready
this is very hard to shut your brain off
um it's it really sticks with you
so yeah there was some times where just
heavy subject matter would stick with
you and you would think about it and
keep you up and
you know of course you worry a bit um
but
i really believe that uh today demi is
is working on herself
so much and really has gotten to the
root a lot of those things that she's in
the best place she's been
um but again she is she's not fixed we
always talked about how this style
it's very hard to wrap up a documentary
and say that's the
on a 28 year old she's 28 years old so
this is uh
the end of a chapter and uh i'm really
proud of where she is and the work she's
doing